what's popping Monster Hunters it's me
Mt and welcome back to the heavy spoiler
show y'all spoilers for Monarch Legacy
of monsters episode 7 coming to your
Face's General directions so if you
haven't seen that episode go watch that
before watching this y Dingus like what
the heck are you doing because I'm about
to switch things up a little to focus on
this episode's big Revelations and how
those Revelations could potentially lead
towards a massive monster Multiverse
event maybe even as soon as the new
Godzilla Kong new Empire movie so let's
just get into this thing and oh my God
the hacker formerly known as May used to
work for the big bads of Godzilla versus
Kong Apex cybernetics I knew those
mother freakers were around here
somewhere I thought Michelle Duval was
working for Apex but apparently it was
May who used to work for Apex this
entire time which makes sense
considering May's strong background in
computer programming the word Apex
apparently comes from the first two
letters of the first two words of
Applied experimental Technologies back
when that company was known as AET to
may/ Kora not sure what I'm going to
call this character now that we know
that May isn't actually may anymore so
I'll probably just fluctuate between
those two names got to love a good
Duality theme in a TV show however I did
notice that while cor was snooping
around on AET servers the file browser
that she uses reveals that her AET
computer username was actually may
instead of Kora so either this was like
a continuity mistake on the show's part
or Kora was actually already going by
May before she even had to go on the run
from AET but not only do we learn of
May's true name in Life as Kora Matteo
in this episode but we also learned that
the Curious Kora Matteo discovered some
crazy ass stuff while being a
disgruntled AET employee and by crazy
ass stuff I mean cyborg monkeys like
Jesus Christ apparently AET decided to
go full Elon Musk and started to
inhumanely open up the skulls of
innocent monkeys in order to gain
important cybernetic research data what
a bunch of experiments that were
no doubt the beginnings of what would
become Apex cybernetics Mecca Godzilla
project that we were introduced to in
Godzilla versus Kong and in that movie
we learned that Apex cybernetic CEO
Walter Simmons who gets multiple shout
outs in this new episode of Monarch
repurposed one of these skulls of the
monster gadora in order to create a
Kaiju supercomputer capable of
controlling their man-made monster meca
Godzilla with Apex scientist Ren Cawa in
the Pilot's chair wearing a helmet that
connected his own mind with the Techno
Organics of that gadora super computer
Walter Simmons's main goal with Mecha
Godzilla and Apex cybernetics as a whole
was to become the new Apex predator on
Earth after Godzilla revealed to
humanity that they were just tiny ants
on a much bigger planet housing Godlike
monsters and also to reap the corporate
and political benefits that being the
most powerful man on the planet brings
because Rich dudes going through midlife
crisises always be doing some wild ass
like I honestly would not be
surprised to see Elon Musk attempt
something like this if kiji were real in
our universe like that dude already
killed so many monkeys in real life so
Jesus Christ God knows what he would do
but anyways it seems like kora's coding
work with AET has been crucial to the
development of Ren swa's cybernetic
neural interface helmet which is of
course why cor discovers AET was running
their messed up experiments on innocent
monkeys who just want to eat a banana
and convert that banana into throwable
poop you know just guy things and later
on in the episode when boss lady Brenda
is threatening Kora May with legal
action she reveals to May that she and
AET have got a massive boner for
Godzilla's neurological system and
unlocking its secrets so they can apply
any scientific Revelations towards the
creation of experimental technology that
the company can profit from not only
this but we also learned from Brenda
that AET has already built a strong
connection with the super secretive
Monarch agency by the year 2015 a
connection that only deepens following
the deal that Monarch makes with AET to
release Kora from corporate captivity
this would make sense as at the
beginning of Godzilla versus Kong Apex
CEO Walter Simmons was extremely
familiar with the research of Monarch's
best science scientists which is why we
see him and ren Cawa sneak their way
into the office of former Monarch
scientist Nathan Lind to recruit his
nerd brain to find the mysterious power
source that powers the hollow Earth and
all of the creatures that emerge from
one of the hollow Earth's many many many
Wormhole tunnels we actually see one of
those tunnels to the hollow Earth form
next to the pyramids of Egypt in the new
Godzilla Kong new empire trailer and of
course we see Shaw and Michelle's Rogue
group of defected Monarch Specialists
work to close one of those tunnels in
Alaska at the very end of the episode
but hold up now just wait a whole damn
minute here doesn't this all feel sort
of familiar like an organization builds
a cybernetic neural interface unit in
order to link up with another life form
in order to Pilot a giant Mech to fight
massive monsters that emerge from
Subterranean Rifts all over the world
that sounds a lot like a pacific rim job
to
me I hate that I said that but no
seriously remember when Pacific Rim
Uprising director Steven denight said on
Twitter that a crossover between Pacific
Rim and legendary's Godzilla Kong
monsterverse was his long-term plan for
the franchise and something that
legendary was deeply considering I think
that is actually starting to go
down and you know what they should
totally do it too as it would make total
sense considering how the monsterverse
seems to be implying that the hollow
Earth isn't actually in the center of
the earth at all and all of these Vortex
tunnels that populate the planet are
actually wormholes to a completely
separate pocket reality when Apex sends
their gravity resistant Vehicles along
with Kong through one of these Hollow
Earth vortexes in Antarctica in Godzilla
versus Kong what they experience isn't
like they fell through a really long
hole of Darkness until they breached the
Earth's core oh no that's not what
happens because as soon as they step
through that Vortex it appears to act as
a cosmic high-speed warp device that
transports whatever can survive the trip
to a completely separate Dimension
entirely this is actually something that
was teased in the Godzilla versus Kong
prequel Comic Kingdom Kong by Monarch
scientist Houston Brooks as portrayed by
actor Joe Morton in that Kingdom Kong
comic Dr Brooks calls these Hollow Earth
vortexes electrostatic membranes that
separate their reality from the
seemingly separate reality of the hollow
Earth if this is indeed the case then
legendary pictures might just be
implying that both the Monarch Godzilla
universe and the Pacific Rim Universe
are two separate universes that both
connect to the same Hollow Earth pocket
Dimension meaning that all the Kaiju
that have been menacing both universes
appear to be native to the same Hollow
Earth Dimension even the precursor
aliens of the Pacific Rim lore and
that's a possibility that seems Ultra
believable to me especially when you
consider how the Kaiju of Pacific Rim
seem to be powered by a similar blue
energy to the energy source that
empowers the hollow Earth and has caused
all the hollow Earth wild life to mutate
to gargantuan proportions and the reason
why I'm bringing this up is that these
two universes seem to to be paralleling
each other quite a good bit I mean in
both universes Kaiju seem to come out of
nowhere around the same time with 24
being the big year for the Monarch
universe and 2013 being when Pacific Rim
saw their first Kaiju with Monarch
Humanity responding in a similar way to
the Pacific Rim Universe by creating a
massive robotic monster with a plasma
cannon Super similar to the plasma
cannons found on Gypsy danger in the
Pacific Rim universe but anyways the
point is in a series heavily rooted in
the concept of dualities and parallels I
would not be surprised if it was teased
that the Godzilla monsterverse is a
parallel reality to the Pacific Rim
Universe with the bridge between them
both being the hollow Earth also known
as the antiverse to the Jagger Pilots of
the Pacific Rim world and Kora might
have actually helped the scientific
minds of the Monarch Universe with
developing cybernetic neural drifting
technology like Jer Pilots use to
connect with each other's minds I mean
hell Ren sarawa even connects his own
mind to a Kaiju to control a robot just
like Charlie Day new Geisler does and
Pacific Rim uprising like I definitely
feel like we were dealing with the
beginnings of a huge monster Multiverse
now but only time will tell but anyways
moving on WE of course got to talk about
Lee Shaw and Michelle Duval and their
invasion of Monarch Outpost 88 in
Fairbanks Alaska because like I alluded
to before it appears that Lee's main
goal in the series is plugging up all
these blue radioactive vortexes that
lead towards the hollow Earth in
previous videos I assumed that Lea was
trying to protect Kaiju life in order to
honor the life of the late KO Randa who
did not want to see human aggression on
these monstrous creatures at all but it
turns out that Lee doesn't give a
singular damn about whether these Kaiju
live or die as evidenced by him and his
people willingly detonating those
explosives on the frost mole that
attacked him all Lee seems to care about
is helping out koo's beloved Godzilla
instead specifically by making
Godzilla's job as Earth's Kaiju
custodian irrelevant because if Lee and
his team can find a way to plug up all
of these holes to the hollow Earth then
nobody has to lose their lives to a Muto
attack attack or a Muto battle ever
again and Godzilla can go back to sleep
for Millennia in peace with Shaw having
lost both KO and Bill Randa to Kaiju and
Michelle Duvall herself still reeling
over the loss of her sister Sandra in
the first Godzilla movie them two
forming an alliance with a bunch of
defective Monarch agents who feel like
monarch isn't doing enough to save lives
makes sense but the character whose
motivations are still shrouded in
mystery is of course the elusive Hiroshi
Randa and his Kaiju callar 9000 that he
got exhibit to hook up to to his pickup
truck yes I just made a Pimp My Ride
joke in 2023 just deal with it okay I'm
old I'm not proud of it either but
considering what we know about the gamma
radiation simulator from Dr Suzuki and
the Randa it would appear that Hoshi
isn't actually trying to summon Godzilla
like the Randa Children First assumed it
might just be trying to use science to
figure out where exactly Godzilla is
emerging from and how exactly Godzilla
is able to pinpoint the exact location
of Kaiju from anywhere on the planet
which is why Hiroshi has a map of a
bunch of Hollow Earth Vortex locations
and has been traveling around the world
with a miniaturized gamma radiation
simulator by activating this gamma
device in empty open places like deserts
or Barren ice wastelands with high
amounts of gamari readings it seems like
Koshi is trying to get Titans to emerge
so that their emergence can expose
another Doorway to the hollow Earth
because if Humanity can figure out where
all of these doorways are what exactly
is attracting these Kaiju and where
they're coming from they have all the
Intel they need to save a bunch of lives
and we know that 9 years later during
the events of Godzilla versus Kong Apex
cybernetics actually has a pretty
detailed map of the hollow Earth at
their disposal ready to use so it seems
like Apex will inevitably get the
results of the random research but
anyways that is it for this followup of
Monarch Legacy of monsters episode 7 let
us know what you guys thought of the
episode Down Below and what were your
guys' reactions to the AET Apex
cybernetics Revelation let us know let
us know but anyways you can follow me at
mastertainment on Twitter or Instagram
or wherever I am on the internet but
most importantly follow heavy spoilers
here on YouTube and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss
anything that we upload and if you like
this video leave a thumbs up it always
helps out the channel but again thank
you guys so much for watching you guys
are amazing people and I love you guys
so so so much and I'll see you guys next
time bye